they don't get deals that
grow their brand
s
[Applause]
God bless the talk boy those things are
almost like five thousand dollars now
it's an expensive gag
um so didn't want to have to do this but
daily wire out of themselves very very
quickly and sure enough
if you see all of the people who who
work there some of whom I have
relationships with they immediately
tried to make this all about money
here's the problem there are a few
problems and I'll go through with some
receipts everything that was said about
negotiations how they transpired beyond
the numerical value which is true and
I'll get to everything else is untrue
I I don't really want to get into that
it's completely irrelevant here's why
going back to the 20-something minute
video 30 minute video you've never heard
me say or write anywhere online
that these offers weren't paying enough
money
why because it's not about the money
it's it's it's kind of unreal to me that
the only thing these people can still
talk about is the money the conversation
was about
conservatism the movement and big Tech
they keep talking about money I'm
talking about a country I'm talking
about a movement I'm talking about
making a difference it's not about the
money and Jeremy and the daily wire know
that how do I know they know that
because after
according to what he said you know I
walked away from the offer I did Place
one more call
to the Daily wire and I made it very
very clear
that it wasn't about money that was not
the topic of conversation there was Zero
as they've tried to portray this
miscommunication
it was one last call where the only
thing that I asked for my only demand
was their word and not even for me
but for other people coming up facing
these kinds of contracts let's say it's
a kid who comes in with 500 000 YouTube
subscribers or something like they're a
hundred thousand let's say some other
kid you're paying you're paying six
figures to come in and do it there's
there's not the penalty of the
demonetization or if they're removed
from iTunes Apple
YouTube
and here's something else I was also
very measured I was painstakingly clear
in taking myself off the table because
it wasn't going to be a right fit that
happens in business all the time
but that we weren't talking about me we
were talking about the futures of other
people who could potentially be in that
position that very disconcerting
position no miscommunication
what I'm talking about is you're
describing a model for everyone a model
for everyone not just let's get get rid
of me here
everyone if there's a penalty for being
demonetized on YouTube because your
business model requires that be a huge
component of it you need to change your
business model or this movement cannot
work Jeremy we I can't imagine my show
trying to come up
and be beholden to YouTube Advertiser
guidelines let alone I mean honestly
being beholden from a conservative
energy with hard strikes right being
removed but let alone being Advertiser
friendly we know how broad those
guidelines are they might as well just
read don't say anything offensive and
they change them at the drop drop of a
hat
I'm not suggesting that the uh
guidelines aren't terrible I'm
suggesting that if making money off of
those platforms is part of how you're
justifying the salary you're paying
something then when or the fee you're oh
I keep saying so the fee you're paying
someone then when those go away
everybody loses money you can't pay the
same amount with less Revenue how about
you create a different business model
now I I know what some of you are
thinking of course telling someone else
hey change your business model I I get
it I'm in no position to say that unless
instead of Monday morning quarterbacking
it
um
here's the thing
I didn't just offer criticisms I offered
a guide on how to here's the deal I want
to sit at the table with people who
granted have an immense amount of power
and have incredibly Deep Pockets that is
all true to be clear and by the way it's
something that I want to have
on our side of the aisle but I offered a
guide on how to do it it is incumbent
this is what this is about it is
incumbent upon conservatives
if we believe what we say
to uncouple to divest if you want to use
that term from Big Tech
right for the business models of the
movement as we move forward to not rely
on playing ball with Facebook
and with YouTube that is something that
we have to move toward you know that
we've been trying to do that here for
years that's why every single show we
say hey if you can watch on Rumble
please do so we're not looking to be
banned on YouTube
but at least we certainly won't
compromise the truth
um in order to be Advertiser friendly
here's the thing here's the thing daily
wire Jeremy and I really do hope that we
can talk at some point please you can
pick up the phone we've done that
we here have found a way to make that
work for proof see election night are
numbers on Rumble there and see the
numbers on Rumble when we get suspended
from YouTube I think it was four times
this last year and I went to Great
Lengths to communicate that to the
people at Daily wire
there can be no next to me if the people
at the top
with with you know the financial
resources
are are doing the big that's that's
being the arm of big Tech what you just
said is well we have to play ball with
big Tech if we want to make money well I
don't why don't you guys follow a model
like I have and scale it that's that's
what I've been doing since 2014. you
know that has been trying to make sure
which I thought we were all doing that
we can all flip the bird to Silicon
Valley this is saying we we need him and
you need to play ball
and by the way before some of you ask
this um look there's always personal
information uh on on phone calls and for
the record I've recorded three people on
phone calls in my life
all three are involved with big Tech
just to be clear the entire call
transcript has been sent to others to
verify without hopefully having to
release the whole thing um and I'll be
on Tim pool show I believe on Monday to
talk about it now this is something else
that's been brought to my attention uh
that uh you know look some people have
been sent out from from daily wire and
have gotten very you know very personal
obviously when we release this video we
we didn't name names and I told you
there are a lot of people in the space
who have made offers and it is true
there are quite a few and there are some
others that have been pretty similar to
this this isn't um an incredible unique
scenario but there have been some good
people out there too and we're still
talking with them
so I do know that some people from daily
wire have sort of have come out maybe
been instructed to have no idea I don't
care they've gotten very personal
I don't want to do that at least I
didn't want to
but now it's sort of necessary for me to
do so
um so these are the only personal things
I will say about the people at Daily
wire uh Andrew Clavin is one of my
favorite people of all time
he has an unbelievable skill to make you
feel like the smartest guy in the room
even though I guarantee you he's smarter
than you there are very few people whose
company I enjoy more than Andrew
Cleveland Jordan Peterson
is not only a friend I would go to the
wall for him he's a guy who has changed
the landscape of our country for the
better can't say enough good things
about him Ben Shapiro is possibly the
smartest person I know
that's as personal as I'll get now
here's the thing only after that final
call
after negotiations had followed through
uh pleading
on the side of principle and knowing
that it was completely met with deaf
ears did I come out like I did
see here's the thing daily they keep
talking about a business
well I walked away from the table
because I'm talking like it's about a
country about a movement and this is the
thing the response that I've heard over
the years it's not just now I've been
doing this for a long time you
constantly hear it's just business it's
just business
well guess what
it's not to me
sure I run a business but it's not just
business and let me ask you what have
you ever heard someone say it's just
business when they're doing the right
thing
ever hear someone give 250 000 to
charity and say it's just business
and here's something I would like to ask
you because I know that they've tried to
play the identity politics and you know
misrepresent the whole uh financial
situation but yeah over the course of
four or five years the total operational
budget meaning 25 30 employees all of
the costs security health insurance
would have been somewhere in the the 50
million dollar ballpark uh for that
total operational budget that is true
okay
first off I think it's a good thing for
conservative companies out there to be
generating or capable of generating far
more than that
and be better than just Disney and just
Netflix and just Hulu Plus and
I like the people who are in charge of
that to be people who are willing to
walk away from that if it comes with
strings attached
with people who hate everything you
stand for so
let's take that at face value okay
I want you to ask yourself this question
okay put yourself in my shoes
what would it take
how much do your principles matter to
you
what kind of a headspace would you have
to be in
to walk away full stop from 50 million
dollars
let me ask you even further
what would it take for you to be willing
to walk away from at least 50 million
dollars
because of it causing harm
to someone else it doesn't even affect
you
but the next kid
I've talked about this you know you have
it in comedy I don't I'm never going to
be the guy who pulls the ladder up
after me
what motivates me
is not money of course everyone here
likes nice things they want to make a
living you've heard me say this many
times I want to pass the torch
I want there to be someone else to do
this it can't happen
if this is how our movement is
structured
and and you know that by the way
this could do irreparable damage to the
movement of the country and the people
who've fought so hard for the ground
gained if we've decided to get in bed
with these people who want to strip it
away I'm asking would you walk away
what would it take for you to walk away
from 50 million dollars because it's
true that's exactly what I did
it's exactly what I'm doing and so long
as these contracts out there include
enforcement
of big Tech of punishing
conservative creators
on behalf of the people we claim to
fight and the people who have long since
demonetized us and can't stand me and
part of me doesn't blame them
as long as these contracts include that
not even for me but the next person I
wouldn't take a billion dollars
and certainly not if you understand in
context when behind closed doors
I know and these people know and
acknowledge exactly what's being done
to the next generation of creators
so they don't get deals that
make a salary and grow their brand
that you then own
parts of it I don't on it they can when
their contracts up they can still go out
and they'll most famous they can keep
doing their show so go to a show
somewhere else
they'll be in a far far better place you
can help to make them
no no I'm not alone about this contract
this contract owns it in perpetuity even
after the contract you're paying a lease
but getting ownership
so this contract is
look I understand they're going to be
differing opinions on this I understand
that as someone who does run a business
and has to 20 I think maybe 25 employees
I don't know we're expanding
um I understand people run businesses
differently and have different
priorities
here's the thing I I would genuinely
still daily wire Jeremy love to sit down
at the table
and explain to you
how you can make all of this work
how you can scale what we do
and not have to be beholden to the
people who
we all go out and claim that we're
fighting
and especially with all of the financial
resources
that you have which by the way are very
impressive and by the way uh since
Fielding requests for people who sent
this in uh under uh who you guys are
under these kinds of contracts right
you've sent in your emails if you're
looking uh to either join a network or
looking to navigate these contracts
we've been flooded I'm going to try and
get to all of you
but here's the thing let me give you my
word right now my word everyone you can
timestamp it call me on it here at mug
club we
will never take any ownership over your
social media platforms or your channels
and I don't want a dime ever of your
YouTube Revenue
you make your own decision as to whether
you want to be monetized or not some
people want to
some people don't
I just have a problem with requiring
that you do and penalizing you
if you don't and to
daily wire to the rest of the people out
there give me a call
and
look let me put it this way
if you give me your word this is all
that matters here just give me your word
that there will never be a clause in a
contract again for some unsuspecting kid
or someone who doesn't have the luxury
to walk away from 50 million dollars as
I did true guilty as charged give me
your word that you will not penalize
them 25 for demonetization another 20
percent for a strike another 20 Facebook
Spotify Apple up to eighty percent just
give me your word
that that Clause that that spirit will
not be in any contract sent out to
anyone else who's at the front lines
fighting for this country
and we're done
all of this stops right now you will
never hear from me again I will go out
and sing your Praises you can pick up
the phone you have my word that's all it
is
that's all this is about
in the interim to everyone else
stop bigcon.com
be a signatory I'll see you uh Monday
Tim pool